hey guys come here bringing you some
news I'm intended upcoming new platform
codenamed and X apparently it's going to
both surprised and innovate do my
favorite things that's according to a
chap by the name of Satoru Iwata I guess
he'd know the nintendo president said as
much in a new interview with Japanese
business publication Nick I it was a
spoke albeit briefly and in vague terms
about the company's mysterious new
platform codenamed NX and although we
didn't really offer much in terms of
specifics he did suggest that the annex
aims to catch gamers through surprise
and other sorts of innovation if you
only expand upon existing hardware it's
dull owatta said in the report as
translated by Kotaku in some shape or
form we're always thinking about how we
want to surprise players as well as our
desire to change each person's video
gaming life the water officially
announced the NX during a presentation
in Japan recently demonstrating
Nintendo's continued commitment to
gaming hardware as proof that Nintendo
maintains strong enthusiasm for the
dedicated game system business let me
confirm Nintendo is currently developing
a dedicated game platform with a brand
new concept under the development code
name and X and what to say at the time
to see gain spots full report about the
MX head on over to the link on screen
now so what do you think the NX might be
all about and what kind of surprises and
innovation would you bet on seeing let
me know in the comments down below and
for all the rest of your gaming news
come on back to gamespot